hello everyone and welcome to another
really awesome game from round one of
the candidates tournament 2022 it's
demora java versus alireza
and it is uh
uh also great that i'm showing this game
because today is alireza's birthday it
is his 19th birthday and uh uh well
must feel great to have um
his birthday during the the candidates
tournament uh he is the youngest player
ever to achieve that uh magical uh
rating of 2800 in classical chess and
it's uh well if he if he manages to win
the candidates it's just going to be
spectacular uh but rajabov he's uh
been playing chess for so long he's an
incredibly strong player he's defeated
pretty much everyone there there is in
the chess well not pretty much he's
defeated everyone he's been uh crushing
people uh you know since the age of
kasparov and all the way up to the the
age of magnus so now he he can just beat
anyone and uh he's an incredibly strong
player so definitely a nice match up you
guys will like this one both of them
came very well prepared uh so let's dive
straight into it but first um here's a
nice photo of the venue if you guys want
to see what it looks like here in round
one you can see many photographers here
i think the photographers are allowed
for the first maybe uh 10 10 minutes uh
you know while the players are still in
opening phases so they don't bother the
players and they i believe they move and
then only one photographer is allowed
maybe they've changed this maybe they
haven't i have not seen anything
regarding this on the website and here
is one from a broader angle uh you can
see feed a president arkady dworkovich
making the first move in the game
karwana akamura i'm pretty sure he made
the first move on all boards but again
not absolutely sure
maybe someone else will be making moves
for the second day for the third day
they usually uh give this uh privilege
to the sponsors so it's uh you know you
sponsor the event and
you know you do get your logo
shown all over the place but also you
get to make the first move if you enjoy
uh such things so i just get into the
mood for the game now let's get to the
game it is
with the white pieces and he opens with
d4
alireza replies with knight to f6 we
have c4 e6 knight to f3 and now d5 we
have knight to c3 uh the queen's gambit
declined is on the board and d captures
in c4 alireza goes for the vienna
variation it is an extremely sharp line
and uh he he definitely came here to
fight we have pawn to e4 alireza
abandoned the center so of course our
java will claim the center and now pawn
to b5 defending the c4 pawn with e5
challenging the knight here knight to d5
and knight captures on b5 so this is all
very standard stuff of course both of
them know this very well and now knight
back to b6 guarding the c for pawn i
don't know if i mentioned this but this
is the first ever classical game between
arajabu and firuja if you guys are are
wondering about that uh and bishop to e3
now continuing development uh we have um
even though bishop to e3 is is an
incredibly rare move here bishop to e2
is just what everyone plays rajab
decides to go for bishop to e3 sort of a
sideline prepared specifically for the
candidates knight to c6 and do not
bishop to e2 all it is not surprised by
the bishop to e3 idea bishop to e7 in
the both players castle so castles
castles and now uh knight back to c3 we
have rook to b8 and here
again there are games that reach this
position b3 is the move that is usually
played here uh to challenge that strong
pawn uh because you you might have some
issues here for example if you play a3
then you make a hole in b3 then it can
come to a5 and b3 also the knight might
land on d3 at some point if you put the
bishop on a6 so it's a it's a nasty
looking pawn even though it's a double c
pawn alireza can use this to his
advantage very well and b3 is what's
usually played but we have a3 by the job
of and alireza says all right i'm going
after that b3 square here we have knight
to a5 uh the position again has been
reached before for example uh last time
in 2018 between uh top elite players
mamidarov had this position against
caruana in the same field cup 2018 the
game ended in a draw uh where karwana
played bishop to b7 but here alireza
plays knight to a5 we have queen to c2
developing the queen connecting rooks
and now knight to d5 we have rook 8 to
d1
uh or this is also also a known position
but only within one game valentina
gunina defeated olympia uh here uh with
uh
with uh with this exact same position
but here after bishop to a6 it is a
completely new move so now as of move 14
we have a completely new game
uh so here bishop back to d2 not
allowing this capture because uh well
you you you have to be careful uh
if if knight captures an e3 you're going
to have a messed up one structure and
you don't want to give up the bishop
player too early for nothing so the java
moves the bishop mag bishop d2 this is
also with the threat of just knight
captures and d5 could be
very nasty because then you have to
watch out the knight here is uh
undefended okay still maybe the queen
can capture and defend the knight uh but
you don't want to allow it if if you
don't have to swallow it as it plays
knight to b3 and excellent square for
the knight and now knight to e4 we have
knight captures and d2 alert is that
wins the bishop pair rook captures and
now we have knight to f4 and this is uh
the moment where everyone uh knew that
something was was definitely happening
uh because what is this all about or
java just plays bishop captures on c4
and he says thank you for the pawn what
is the idea behind this move uh but
alireza shows it it is the move from the
thumbnail rook captures on b2 giving up
the exchange uh with no extra pawns he
just has the bishop pair and he wants to
play active chess so queen captures on
b2 it is the only good move for white
here bishop captures on c4 and now we
have rook the c1
and the rook the c1 is already an
incredibly interesting move by rajabov
because uh uh basically rook after d1 is
what seems like the move you have to
play but with rook to c1 he is uh
offering the exchange right back he
wants celeste to go for knights to d3 uh
attack the queen and the rook he would
capture for example rook captures here
bishop captures on the three now knight
g3 and the game continues with alireza
maybe having some problems defending the
two isolated pawns but it shouldn't be a
problem if anything the bishop paris is
is stronger here uh but uh alireza
doesn't go for this he just brings the
bishop back bishop to d5 he doesn't want
the exchange back he wants to keep the
bishop fair and put pressure he wants to
put the queen on a8 and have incredible
pressure along this diagonal so rook
back to e1 defending the knight and the
queen to a8 we have queen to c2
defending the knight here and now uh
alireza has to decide whether it's okay
to capture the pawn on a3 yeah or not
after some consideration already that
captures it and now he's still down the
exchange but he has a past a pawn that
he can start pushing uh here we have
knight after g5 by the job of uh again
with a very deadly threat knight to f6
uh if if lands that's it for alireza for
example you play some like bishop before
you attack the rooks all of a sudden
knight f6 check and black resigns you
have to capture or king hit doesn't
really matter queen h7 will be checkmate
so alireza brings the knight back knight
to g6 to close this diagonal and now
pawn to h4 rajabou now wants to push the
pawn all the way to h5 and uh what can
alireza do here
uh well best is to play bishop to b4
that's exactly what he does
doesn't care about material he just
wants to play the absolute best moves
and that that is why he is so strong so
here h5 uh uh challenging the knight
here and uh the question is what can
alireza play here and this is a a huge
moment for the game uh as uh
you can take uh many different uh uh
routes here for example bishop captures
an e4 seems to be the most solid one uh
point is that now we're attacking the
queen and after knight captures we're
gonna play knight to h4 and now
again what do you play here the knight
the knight from e4 can't really move
because we're going to check mate to the
white king here so we're going to play
h6 uh and now you cannot play g6 that
that would be a pretty pretty big
mistake if you play the g6 then we play
knight to f6 check and it's game over uh
you don't really have a good move here
king to h8 we're gonna play d5 we're
gonna close this diagonal uh and it's
just uh it it's just not uh not possible
to play this anymore with black we are
completely dominating the position if
you capture the pawn here of course you
can't capture with the queen if you
capture the pawn you can even play e6
open up this diagonal so black would
completely fall apart here but okay
after h6 of course you don't have to
play g6 you can play rook to d8 the game
continues and uh it's um you know it's a
game uh but with chances for both sides
so for some reason already doesn't like
this not for some reason he decides that
it is uh
not not good for him and he is uh well a
former 2800 player uh so we should
definitely trust him uh he goes for
bishop captures on d2 he reclaims the
material we have queen captures on d2
and now pawn to h6 chasing away the
knight from g5 but now h captures on g6
h captures on g5 g captures on f7 with
check king captures and now knight
captures with check king to e8 and now
pawn to f3 and if you count to the
material now uh the material is
completely equal uh it is basically a
bishop against the knight with alireza's
king being wide in the open so it is
definitely
uh white who who got the upper hand in
that little skirmish there so king the
d7 improving the the safety of the king
and now knight to e4 now the knight is
hoping to land on c5 it's a dark square
alerza has a light square bishop this
could be great so of course you have to
capture it bishop captures we have rook
captures and now queen to d5 so again
equal material but it is much easier to
play it with white with the black king
being so wide in the open so here queen
before going after the rook here alireza
just plays rook the g a sorry not rook
to be it rook to g8 he wants to start
pushing the g pawn uh we have queen to
a4 with check now going after the a7
pawn queen to c6 and queen captures on
a7 rajabou grabs a pawn here uh but
there was no
good way of of keeping it maybe there
was but alireza says it doesn't really
matter we're gonna be able to hold this
either way so here we have rook to a8
attacking the queen queen to c5 and now
we have a queen trade because if rook
day one check um king will hide on h2
and there's no good way to continue the
king hunt so queen captures on c5 we
have d characters and king to c6 we rook
to g4 and the king captures on c5 now
equalizing but only briefly rook
captures on g7 going for the pawn here
king d5 going after the e5 pawn captures
and captures so now you have this
position uh rook and rook and pawn end
game java is up upon and he has a past g
pawn so can he win this with perfect
play not so much but uh you know uh rook
and games are incredibly tricky and of
course he will he will try to push this
for a win uh rook f7 was played we have
king to d6 king f2 now he starts
bringing the king into the game we have
e5 pawn to g4 he starts pushing the pass
pawn king e6 we have rook to f5 and rook
to a3 now we have rook to f8 uh king to
e7 attacking the rook rook the b8 now
and king to f7 we rook the c8 king to e7
and now rook to c2 just um you know uh
go going
all over the place to see if maybe
alireza makes a silly move with king to
f6 rook to e2 now and rook to b3 rook to
e3 offering the rook trade but of course
you are never doing this rook to b2 with
chuck king to g3 and rook to c2 now
waiting for for white to try and make
progress rook to a3 we have rook to b2
now comes rook to a6 with check king f7
rook to h6 and now rook to b3 we have
king to f2 now comes rook to a3 so just
saying you've got nothing here uh we
have rook to b6 now comes king to e7
king to e2 and now rook to c3 we have
king f2 rook to a3 and now rook back to
b2 we have king qf6 rook to e2 again
trying everything
the the moves are happening quickly now
in the video uh but uh you know for
alireza defending this it took hours
because he has to play the you know
precise moves you do not want to lose an
equal end game even though you are down
a pawn with rook to b3 uh rook to e3
again offering rook trade and rook b to
check we have king g3 rook to c2 rook to
b3 and now rook to a2 we have uh rook to
b6 with check king to f7 and now g5 uh
you either accept the draw or you have
to make a pawn move if you don't make a
pawn move uh then the 50 move rule will
apply and it will be a draw
by 50 move rule so you have to make
either a pawn or important move or a
capture so g5 we have rook to a for now
uh cutting off the king from the fourth
rank and rook to f6 with check king to
e7 we have rook to h6 and now king to f7
not allowing the rook to go anywhere
near the pawn here
rook to h4 now comes rook to a5 we have
king to g4 and now rook to a4 with check
king h5 and now rook to a3 attacking the
f3 pawn pawn to f4 and now he captures
an f4 and he was in this position on
move 71 that rajab and firuja agreed to
a draw and their first ever game in the
2022 candidates tournament ends in a
draw at the point is after rook captures
an f4 check and king g7
there's no way to make progress with
white of course both of them know this
so we can even show it for example rook
before we want to check the black king
we're just going to play row k1 we go
behind the the white king and that's all
we need basically rook b7 check king j8
king h6 you can even put the pawn threat
and some checkmating ideas let's say
rook a6 check pawn to g6 now rook k8 not
allowing checkmate and the once uh okay
you put it upon nothing really happens
if rook g7 would just move king h8 rook
f7 uh or somewhere king to g8 and there
is no way to make uh progress with white
here you always wanted the king in front
of your past pawn if you don't have it
you will not be able to
uh to do anything in most cases of
course there are exceptions uh so after
he captures an f4 they agreed to a draw
and a ver a very very uh interesting
game where uh alvareza prepared a
very very interesting line with the
black pieces this uh
uh
entire thing with with the rook and the
open b file is just uh
incredibly uh interesting uh with bishop
to a6 being the the new movie it has
been played before but then this rook
captures on b2 exchange sacrifice
happened uh and alireza really tried to
make use of his bishop there but uh
rajab did not make it easy for him he
did allow him to sort of go for this
line that we mentioned where uh alireza
accepted the exchange back instead of
going for this bishop captures on e4
idea
but this would be a bit too double edged
as we've said you cannot play g6 you
would have to play rook to d8 and then
you know the game just continues so
uh it would be incredibly sharp but
alireza doesn't want to gamble away his
chances um uh already in round one of
the candidate so i think it was it was
definitely a good decision and they
ended
the game on unpeaceful terms so after he
captures on f4 degree to a draw and that
is what happened in round one
uh so uh that's the game once again
really hope you guys uh enjoyed it uh i
would like to thank chaos dylan andrew
lastova
derek king and aravind kumar vendeli for
a contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
candidates tournament until it finishes
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day